6ème édition du salon du bien-être à
voisins le bretonneux dimanche 26
janvier
à cette occasion les visiteurs ont pu
rencontrer des professionnels implantés
sur une dizaine de stands
chaque année il ya des intervenants
nouveau et on essaye justement de ne pas
faire deux années de suite avec les
mêmes activités
le bien-être c'est être à l écoute de
soi l écoute des autres pour que
justement ce soir monieux cette édition
mettait à l'honneur la découverte de
nouvelles pratiques de relaxation
réflexologie plantaire ou bien encore le
yoga par le rire nouveauté un stand
était consacrée à la compréhension des
bébés ainsi qu'à l'accompagnement des
parents
j'accompagne les mamans ou les couples
avant pendant et après la naissance de
leur bébé touche vraiment le bien-être
parce que ça va être le bien-être de la
maman et du couple et du bébé parce que
je vais les accompagner vraiment de
manière émotionnelle et pas que médical
ya plein de petites choses qui sont un
peu comme un mezze finalement dans ce
salon on va puiser un petit peu dans des
choses
qu'on ne connaissait pas peut-être se
joindre à de nouveaux ateliers et puis
de faire de nouvelles découvertes pour
le bien-être se recentrer sur soi et se
détendre à chacun sa formule qui marche
et pour ceux qui n'ont pas pu venir à ce
6e salon une nouvelle édition aura lieu
l'année prochaine